hello and welcome to my Python tutorial
regarding how to send the email within
your Python script I have a few
different reasons for doing this you
could have maybe a web app with Python
running in the background and you want
to be able to send an email within it or
I use it personally I have a couple
servers and just computers that are
constantly doing various tasks and if
something trips up or something happens
it will notify me via email and tell me
something is wrong so if I'm not at home
I can get the email on my phone and then
remote desktop and figure out what what
needs to be done so anyway I'm obviously
sending emails I mean there's a whole
lot of reasons you might want to send an
email so anyway this is going to be a
tutorial how to do that you don't
actually have to download anything
SMTP live is actually built into the
vanilla installation of Python so all
you really need to do is import smtp lib
now we're going to be using the Gmail
SMTP servers so in order to do that all
you really need is a gmail account that
you will actually be logging into to do
this if you don't have one it's really
easy to make one so just go ahead and
make it so anyway all you really have to
do now is well if you have an email you
need content to that email so we'll just
say content and we'll just say example
email stuff here next what we need to do
is specify the SMTP mail server that we
want to use and then the port that we
want to use with it so we're going to
call this mail equals SMTP live dot
capital SMTP and then in here are the
two parameters I would just mentioned
you've got the server and then the port
in the case of Google it's
smtp.gmail.com really tough stuff and
the port you can either use port 465 or
port 587 with Gmail that might change in
the future so if something's going wrong
you might want to check up on that
now the next thing that we want to do is
you want to identify yourself to the
server and there's a couple different
ways you can do that there's a hello and
there's also as blow anyway hello is
just for a regular and Ella or hello is
for the esmtp server and esmtp just
stands for extended smtp so if you're
using a server that has that that's what
you would use so mail dot eh l empty
parameters next thing we want to do is
start what's called TLS mode and TLS
stands for transport layer security so
this means that any SMTP command that's
coming after this is going to be
encrypted so the reason we want to do
this is the next step is to actually log
in to our email account so we want to
make sure that's encrypted so the next
thing we want to do is mail dot start
TLS empty parameters and now we want to
do we want to login so you would do mail
dot login and here you would have you
know your email and your password and
now we actually want to send the email
pretty easy command here mail dot send
mail and then in here you specify
there's actually three parameters to
this the first parameter is going to be
the from email so you should use the
same email that you've logged into now
when people start learning about how
like SMTP servers work and you could do
this within like DOS and stuff to is
people are like oh you can spoof emails
you know and I just want to say that
first of all generally like the
immediate idea is like - let's let's
send an email from the FBI or or let's
send them an email from Obama bad idea
because that would be considered
impersonating a federal employee that is
a federal crime
also just spoofing an email address
overall can get you into some trouble as
well so so try to refrain from playing
praying those kinds of jokes on your
friends so from email use the same email
as you say here also if you do spoof the
if you say it's something else then
other than it was then
and a lot of times that's going to go to
the junk mail so just keep that in mind
as well if you actually want the email
to arrive don't lie
the next field here is going to be the
receiver receiver and then finally the
content of that email that you'll want
to put in there so once you've got all
of that that email has now been sent and
now the last thing you want to do is
close the connection so you would just
do mail that close and that is it to
send an email within Python so what I
thought would be kind of cool is I'll
I'll pull up my email I'll fill in these
parameters and actually send this
example email just show you guys that it
works although you can try it yourself
alright so just to show you guys real
quick the email actually being sent pop
it up here and looks like the email is
probably sent so we'll just wait a
second it should appear in our mailbox
here maybe not fresh there we go
head to refresh but anyway so there's
the email you can see it's from me
there's no subject but it came from here
example email stuff here you the idea so
anyway that's just the real basic how to
send an email within Python obviously
you want to eventually learn probably
how to put a subject in there and
there's also other things you might want
to be able to put an email or about like
HTML maybe images all kinds of stuff so
if you are running maybe an automatic
mailing system possibly you might want
to be able to do some more tricks so
I'll probably put another video out on
some added stuff that you can do
alongside this but that's the basics of
sending an email I will just mention a
couple of things if you are having a
problem with the email sending make sure
you didn't name the file email dot PI
for whatever reason if anybody knows the
reason
please I'm curious put it below why it
doesn't work but if you call it email
dot pi it just it compiles the Python
script like as if it's being a mug it's
really strange I'm not sure why it's
white
doing that but anybody knows exactly
what is happening do let me know but
yeah if you call it email dot PI it's
not going to work so if you are using
this on your web server and your license
is working and you don't have like
errors enabled or something you might
have a no idea what's actually happening
but yeah don't call it email dot pi so
anyway as always thanks for watching
thanks for your support your
subscriptions and until next time